yankees astros you can hear in the
background they're booing already
this is going to be a series that the
yankee fans have been waiting for for a
while
this has turned into a great rivalry it
has i expect there to be fireworks i
expect there to be smoke machines our
voice is getting a little bit louder but
yeah it's going to be a unique
environment for these guys to go out
there because
there is a lot of history between these
two teams domingo hermann is towing the
slab into boogie down bronx tonight
fifth start
numbers are getting better progressively
just four walks that's really good
jose altuve will lead it off for the
astros boy these fans are
really ready and don't forget there's
only 10 000 at the most
and we are really giving it to altoo i
would repeat what they're saying but i
can't would get fined by the
fcc oh you could repeat it but you
turned the radio station to a bowling
alley
well altuve should expect three days of
this
that one has popped up
makes the play one out no one on for
left fielder michael brantley
rounded right side torres makes the pull
to the right alex bregman will step in
there with two outs and nobody on
there is just no way to replicate the
adrenaline rush that you get when you
have fans like this that are so pumped
up and into the game
so that will pump up the yankees but
will it intimidate the ashes
bregman drives one deep to left field
and that will silence a few of the
yankees fans as he puts one into the
bullpen a solo home run and the astros
out in front
how good must that feel for alex
pregnant i see a lot of emotion there so
you know the booing and the cheering
sure it means something uh here is
jordan alvarez
deals the full count swing and a miss
alvarez
down on strikes the one and only zach
grinky on the season he just keeps going
and going he's still going
only six walks that's the secret sauce
for him throws everything at you maybe
nothing above 90 miles an hour and
here's dj
up the middle and through for a base hit
single for lamehu to start it off so
here is the red hot
giancarlo sandy has the average up to
271
on nine game hitting streak driven deep
to left field
bradley back on the track at the wall
sia a two-run home run for stanton
the yankees answer back they lead
two-to-one
no one in this place has sat down that's
the way to get back
immediately you know here is aaron judge
3-2 judge walks
here's the cleanup hitter geo orchella
ground ball basic right field
in the first base hole judge goes to
second and holds on
so it's first and second for the yankees
with no one out
here's glaiber torres 3-2 walk them
bases loaded
and that'll bring up clint frazier let's
see if they could turn
two there's one and there's two as judge
scores
yankees lead three to one two outs now
for altuve
can hear the crowd you know what's
amazing about what happened in 2017
altuve has defied all odds to become a
great player and he was one of the
beloved players of the game
and what happened in 2017 in the
subsequent
admission has changed all that just
flipped it
up on its ear did he go yes he did
altuve down on strikes
so the astros go down in order to the
delight of the stadium crowd
go to the fourth inning where domingo
armad has only allowed one base runner
so far through three
brantley will lead things up michael
drives one deep to right field
that ball's hit really well that ball is
into the upper deck
michael bradley to the sweet level in
yankee stadium
that feels sweet it's a three to two
game one on and one out
and that will bring up goriel julie has
the best numbers against vermont in this
lineup
julie sends one to left field well hit
has he done it again against armand that
ball's gone
that's gonna be ruled a double oh right
off the top of the wall
how about that the astros have tied it
up a new life for zach grinky in the
astros is three apiece in the bronx
bottom of the fourth clint frazier the
left fielder is up
and the first pitch is a slow breaking
ball strike one
wow 53 miles per hour frazier
with a ride grin after that the wind up
in the 2-2
little hesitation strike three fastball
at the knees and it's a strikeout one
away
that's grinky's third two out on a
runner at second for gioverchella one
for two with a single driven to right
center by her shell the straw is back
and he makes the catch onto the warning
trap
well struck by urshela but the ballpark
able to hold it
so one on and one out for alvarez 2-1
rounded up the middle oh beautiful play
there's one
on to first double play oh what a twin
killing
to end the inning just an outstanding
double play by the yankees
bases are loaded for la mayhew last
thing the astros wanted
i mean this is the guy if you're aaron
boone you want to be up in this
situation
soft ground ball to third going to be a
tough play bregman fields fires
not in time and the ball gets past
gorilla
here comes hikashioka he'll score here
comes odor
he'll score and the yankees lead six to
three
lemayo is at second and quickly
both sides come out a yankee is hurt and
an astro is hurt
greg nitto door down martine maldonado
down
very awkward collision at home plate
with odor and maldonado
odor's left leg went right into
maldonado's head
so this is bad for everybody now
audeure's getting up
and he's going to need some help coming
off and his left leg is clearly hurt
while donato will walk off the field
ugly ugly situation he's walking on his
own in the dugout and boy
that's a great sign yes so the yankees
have a 6-3 lead
so here's stan lemay who is on second
soft ground ball right side and through
for base hit lemay who runs third
he'll score it's the third hit of the
night for stanton
in rbi single and the yankees lead seven
to three
puts runners on the corners higashiyoka
will be the batter three two got him
strike three as scruff gets his man
and screams into his glove as he marches
back
to his dugout yankees ninth walk on the
night
cody you're not gonna win too many games
uh when you walk nine hitters
you've got some some guys on the other
side that could put the ball out of the
park too
so the bases are loaded for clay for
tourists ground ball left side to his
left bregman he gathers it in it throws
to first in time to in the inning
yankees load them up but don't score
chad green will be the yankees fifth
pitcher houston
down to their final out that one's
driven out to left center field on the
run
is gardner still going he's there makes
the play
and the yankees win 7-3 a yankee crowd
that was in it from start to finish
delirious has the yankees finish this
one off
just a fantastic atmosphere at the
stadium